so we have a new bribery for up from story
about Donald Trump.
Donald Trump
is now being used of having promised WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange a pardon if he were
to publicly deny Russia's involvement in the
hacking of the DNC back during the 2016 election,
which of course would have been a lie because
we know that that is exactly the way it went
down.
Every aspect of this story is pure corruption
and it's down to the details exactly what
we would expect.
That even involves Congressman Russia, the
former, that's the nickname for the former
Congressman Dana Rohrabacher, who is also
tied up in this entire thing.
So this is not Trump's Ukraine, Biden corruption,
extortion, bribery.
This is not Trump funneling money from taxpayers
and donors through the secret service into
his own hotels and resorts.
We've talked about that.
This is not other emoluments violations by
Donald Trump.
We've talked about that.
This is a new corruption story about Donald
Trump, so it's widely accepted that Russia
hacked the DNC back during the 2016 election.
Donald Trump has been very eager to question
or deny that since day one because it fuels
the narrative that Russia preferred Trump
over Hillary Clinton, which we of course now
know to be true as well.
Julian Assange is the founder of WikiLeaks.
He is now under arrest.
He's facing extradition.
Previously had been holed up to avoid arrest
in the Ecuadorian embassy in London for years
and years to avoid that extradition.
Eventually he overstayed his welcome.
There were allegations about hygiene and all
sorts of other stuff.
In any case, at some point, the Ecuadorian
embassy said no muss, so Julian Assange has
lawyer now asserts in court during a pre extradition
hearing that Donald Trump through proxies
offered Julian Assange a pardon if he were
to agree to help cover up the truth of the
Russia hack.
Meaning Trump wanted a syringe to sow disinformation
seeking to distance Russia from the DNC hack.
And this is a mind blowing allegation.
The person who allegedly communicated the
offer to Julian Assange was none other than
former Republican Congressman Dana Rohrabacher,
a guy himself known for his sketchy connections
to Russia.
Rohrabacher went to London in 2017 to make
this offer.
It is alleged Rohrabacher widely known as
Congressman Russia and as Putin's favorite
Congressman.
The claim was made in court.
That quote, mr Rohrabacher going to see mr
[inaudible] and saying on instructions of
the president that he was offering a pardon
or some other way out if a Savage said Russia
had nothing to do with the DNC leaks.
The white house was asked about this allegation
and they issued a very carefully worded denial.
Check it out.
Uh, Stephanie Grisham, the white house press
secretary, who we never see cause she doesn't
do press briefings.
Said quote, the president barely knows Dana
Rohrabacher other than he's an ex Congressman.
He's never spoken to him on this subject or
almost any subject.
It is a complete fabrication and a total lie.
This is probably another never ending hoax
and total lie from the DNC.
Notice that the statement says Trump barely
knows Rohrabacher.
Well, you don't have to know him at all to
get him to communicate a possible pardon to
Julian Assange.
The statement says, Trump has never spoken
to Rohrabacher about this.
Of course, any number of middlemen could have
passed along the message to Rohrabacher and
then they blamed the DNC completely without
evidence, which of course has nothing to do
with this.
As far as we know, this is an assertion that
was made in a British court by the lawyer
of Julian Assange and there is nothing to
do with the DNC as far as we currently have
evidence.
This isn't the first time that Rohrabacher
his trip to London was asserted to be connected
to an Asana.
Pardon?
Two months after this trip happened, the wall
street journal reported what Rohrabacher was
doing in that trip was trying to arrange a
deal for Donald Trump to pardon Julia and
it's on, so it's not even the first time that
that has been suggested.
The white house confirmed at the time that
Rohrabacher had spoken to Donald Trump's chief
of staff, John Kelly, about the plan to free
Julian Assange.
But it wasn't clear who had personally spoken
to whom did Trump speak to Rohrabacher or
not.
But it doesn't really matter because you don't
need to have a direct conversation for the
assertion to be true.
The daily beast says that in 2018 Rohrabacher
told the intercept that he was blocked from
discussing the plan with the president because
Kelly and others thought it would look like
collusion.
So case in point when the white house says
Trump never spoke to Rohrabacher about it,
we have a report from the daily beast that
says they were deliberately communicating
through others to avoid it looking like they
were colluding on this.
So is this believable?
Of course it is.
Do we have reason to doubt it?
Well, with any of these stories, we should
apply a healthy level of skepticism.
In this case, we have reports from two different
news agencies in the past combined now with
the assertions by Julian Assan, just lawyer
and the fact that this is how Donald Trump
has known to work.
Trump has implicitly, uh, um, uh, suggested
that people who keep their mouth shut about
him could get a pardon calling them strong
people who don't crack.
Like Paul Manafort.
You might remember Trump has withheld aid
to Ukraine unless they smear Biden.
He got caught and ultimately had to release
the aid.
This is how Donald Trump has always done business
as a real estate developer in New York down
to the details.
This is how Trump operates.
And in the end we go back to if there's nothing
wrong, if there's nothing with Russia here,
why again, is there more of an effort uncovered
that was geared towards hiding Russia's involvement
in that DNC hack?
And like I told you yesterday, Trump and pardons,
these are political tools that he uses and
he will keep using them to his advantage if
he is reelected
to
a second term that you can be sure of.